hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing magic
specifically what it is where it comes
from and why only some people can
Channel it expanding on that we're going
to be looking at the physiological
differences between wizard kind and
muggle kind attempting to identify
biological characteristics that may
differentiate the two magic is defined
as the power of apparently influencing
the course of events by using mysterious
or Supernatural forces which on paper
seems like a fairly fitting description
however the part of the definition I
take issue with is the supernatural
component as this implies that magic is
beyond scientific comprehension
Supernatural means just that a force
that transcends the laws of nature but
is Magic really Supernatural is it a
force that relies on religious influence
or can it be biologic quickly explained
from what I can tell this aspect of
magic seems to have been interpreted
very differently across a broad spectrum
of Harry Potter fans some fans view have
viewed magic in the Harry Potter series
as being based on science a natural
force that can be studied and understood
through the study of magical Theory and
the practice of magic reinforcing this
is the fact that the use of magic in the
series often involves scientific
principles such as the conservation of
energy however many others view have
viewed magic in this series as being
based on religion a mysterious and
unknowable force that is beyond the
understanding of mere mortals in fact
this religious correlation is one of the
main reasons that the Harry Potter books
became temporarily one of the most
banned books to have ever hit shelves
under the assumption that the Magic in
the books was religious in nature many
Christian groups strongly opposed it the
reason for this being that witchcraft is
directly denounced in the Bible but I'm
here to set the record Strange Magic is
science-based a fact that has been
confirmed by JK Rowling herself
though many interpreted the Magical
World of Harry Potter to be driven by
wiccanism a modern Pagan witchcraft
religion JK Rowling has since insisted
that the Magic in Harry Potter is
entirely secular a product of Science
and not religion it does not depend on
active intervention by a God or Gods
this is consistent with her condemnation
of Wicca which believes magic to be
spiritual in nature it's a different
concept of magic to the one laid out in
the books so I don't really see how they
can co-exist Okay so we've confirmed
that magic is indeed science based but
what does that mean exactly in essence
magic is an inherent part of the fabric
of the universe and exists as a kind of
energy that can be harnessed and
manipulated by those with the ability to
do so those possessing the appropriate
genetic makeup this theory is supported
by the fact that magic is present in
various forms in the natural world such
as in the plants and animals that in
habit The Wizarding World furthermore it
appears that magic is somehow linked to
the human psyche presenting itself as a
manifestation of the power of the mind
this theory is supported by the fact
that many magical spells and
incantations in the series involve the
use of intention and visualization as
well as the power of belief witches
Wizards and other creatures who possess
magical abilities bear a gene that
allows them to exploit the natural
forces of magic this is reinforced by JK
Rowling magic is a supernatural force
that changes aspects of the world at
fundamental levels the ability for
humans to use magic is a hereditary
trait passed down from a person's
ancestors which allows witches and
wizards to practice it rather than being
a mystical or unnatural Pursuit that
defied the laws of nature however magic
simply allowed those who could wield it
to exploit them in very specific and
creative ways that muggle Sciences were
unable to replicate in essence witches
Wizards are essentially Advanced or
mutated human beings that have either
inherited the ability to exploit magic
through their ancestry or in rarer
occasions independently developed the
ability to exploit magic through a
genetic mutation they have advanced
physiologies heightened perception and
if trained enough have the ability to
control the world's elements to some
extent it would also appear that besides
possessing the magical Gene witches and
wizards have some other notable
physiological benefits that classify
them as advanced humans these traits
include longer lifespans though not to a
significant extent and a resistance to
most common illnesses basically witches
and wizards are just enhanced humans
which means that their existence
pre-magic is the same as the original
ancestors of humans who are thought to
have first existed about 6 million years
ago over millions of years humans
developed and evolved and so it
shouldn't be surprising to anyone that
eventually humans started showing
Supernatural capabilities the ability to
perform magic though the origins of
wizard kind in Harry Potter are
undefined we do have some information
about the first documented magical being
the first known wizard across all
continents was a wizard by the name of
the ayamanek who were held from Egypt as
far back as 2600 BC there is little to
no information available on yamanek
other than where he was from and the
period in which he lived but I do wonder
if wizard kind went back further than
that or if he was truly the first though
we've been able to narrow down magic to
some sort of scientific origin the exact
origins of magic are still unclear to
this day no one knows whether the
Inception of wizard kind was born from
humans randomly discovering their
magical abilities inadvertently
exploiting the magical gene or whether
some sort of breadcrumb was discovered
and subsequently pursued nevertheless at
some point in time the innate ability to
perform magic was uncovered in humans
introducing the beginnings of wizard
kind and the start of a new chapter were
the natural force of magic could begin
to be harnessed however I'd also like to
add that I very much doubt humans were
the first to exploit magic there are a
variety of species in the magical world
which I imagine far proceeded was it
kind creatures like goblins and elves
and based on Rowling's definition of
magic it can be inferred that there are
no apparent differences in the type of
magic that they perform all magical
forms of life in Harry Potter simply
possess the ability to wield magic and
it's not necessarily that they
themselves are magical only that they
are able to take advantage of the magic
around them and while the ability to
perform magic is a genetic variation in
and of itself it's also worth mentioning
that some witches and wizards have
undergone what appears to be even
further mutation these groups are able
to tap into Magic on an even deeper
level and possess abilities that are
seemingly unachievable by witches and
wizards without the subsequent mutations
these subspecies include but are not
limited to metamorph Magi those born
with the ability to dramatically change
their physical appearance at will Sears
those born with the ability to see or
predict future events and parcel mouths
those born with the ability to speak
parcel tongue allowing them to
communicate with snakes and while these
examples paint a picture of the types of
witches Wizards that can exist as a
result of hereditary born traits it's
also worth mentioning that there are
also many witches Wizards that have been
able to achieve similar abilities
through learned traits and while magic
is scientific in nature and not the
religious based Force presumed by many
it certainly doesn't take away from the
fact that it's a mysterious enigmatic
force of nature with seemingly Endless
Possibilities if we consider that the
first glimpses of magic became known as
latest 2600 BC then I think we can
reasonably infer that magic will
continue to be exploited on an
exponentially growing scale in 10 000 or
even 100 000 years who knows what might
be achievable via the magical Gene and
that's it for this video if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign